Alexander Graham Bell of what Fame what
did he do he invented cellphone right uh
he devised a solution to this he looked
at this situation he said this is this
is not good
he also wanted to have two different
wires because he invented the telephone
and the telephone is going to have
signal was going in and see was going
out right so he had this exact problem
okay
his solution was ingenious he desired
this okay now can you see it what is
this I don't know how closely it's a
real close-up because I wanted to get a
little shorter than that oh this is what
we call a twisted pair twisted pair you
can see why it's called twisted pair
because all the wires are doubled up
there in pairs they're matched up with
another one they're not just flying out
on their own and secondly they're not
just sort of running parallel to each
other they are twisted on each other
okay now if you take any of the ethernet
cables that are here in the room right
the blue ones and you cut one open don't
do it okay this is what you would see
are always identical in fact okay so
you've got a few pairs in there and
they're all twisted
twist it what difference does that make
what difference does it make when the
two wires are not running just parallel
to each other but you know they're sort
of like a helix even that kind of thing
in 3d space though what difference would
have made that's exactly right
when you've got these in a different
physical arrangement right what you're
going to actually do and this is Bell
was a really smart guy right he worked
out that it would greatly reduce
electromagnetic interference okay when
they were coiled around each other in
this way that they wouldn't muck around
with each other's signals nearly as much
and not just that but they're combined
magnetic field because they're still
giving one off right their combined
magnetic field
what actually helped to resist
interference coming from outside it
wouldn't completely cancer that but it
would mean that if there was like a mild
amount nearby
these ways would sort of protect each
other if that made sense that's why
they're all paired okay each one is
protecting another one if you added a
third one in it wouldn't quite work
because the magnetic fields interact in
a different way and if you had one that
was just like its own and now over here
there would be nothing to protect it
okay so twisted pair there are two main
kinds
here's unshielded twisted-pair and
shielded twisted-pair so remember I said
that when they're twisted together they
would help to ward off a lot of
interference but not all of it okay so
what sometimes um and that means there
unshielded there's nothing else around
here except maybe a bit of plastic what
some people have designed is a kind of
sheath that goes around each of the
pair's
okay that is either made of an insulator
or some other kind of material which
again will try and shield out some that
magnetic interference okay
I'm shielded shielded now unshielded
twisted-pair is the dominant type of
cabling in the world in all
communication systems okay I all
Ethernet cables are basically UTP unless
you get really special expensive stuff
okay it's quite cheap to produce because
what you've got here is not very
sophisticated you're a copper wire in
quite thin and it just is wrapped around
itself and we've got machines that can
do that very very quickly okay